if you practice yoga could you
potentially be worshiping hindu deities
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness what's up
everybody thank you for joining us for
another episode of led live and we got
our guest mike shreve here again good
we're back looking forward to some
wisdom on this topic but first we want
to say thank you to all our donors out
there without you we could not have this
show this channel would not exist so we
love you and appreciate you so much and
you have been a blessing to us as well
as many other people who get to watch
this show for free every week and if you
want to support this channel you can do
so by going to little lightstudios.tv
and towards slash give i think you can
find it on the website and also you can
become a patreon donor which is a
monthly donor and you can also buy our
t-shirts at lightware.shop
you can really wear your witness you can
be a walking billboard for the gospel
and it might just spark up a
conversation to help you break the ice
on spiritual topics like that so we want
to get into
it says 10 yoga poses that offer worship
to hindu deities right when i got into
yoga i didn't know that was going on i
didn't know i was actually doing that
when i assume those poses right and i
know a lot of people are like well i
don't you know i don't do anything
religious i just
it helps my back i do the stretches or
whatever
um what do you say to i'm sure you hear
this all the time people that say the
stretch has really helped their back and
stuff i always say
you don't have to do yoga to do
stretches right right there is a
difference
they don't have uh a copyright on
stretching right
you know so but there are certain poses
that
originate from hinduism
right definitely and the traditions
are that certain poses are consecrated
to or offered to specific deities
and people are oblivious to that for the
most part they'll go to a yoga studio
and i think the danger is this that
maybe the person involved in going to a
yoga studio has the mindset i'm just
tuning up my body i'm just getting
better and fit and more fit so that i
can uh have a healthier life
and yet they get drawn in little by
little
into a world view that is very
non-biblical and non-christian i hear
that so many times when i've heard
testimonies of new age it always starts
without i was raised christian i started
practicing yoga and one thing leads to
another the word yoga means yoke
and the implication is you're yoked with
god
but the god you're being yoked with
is an impersonal life force is that
brahma brahman brahman
brahman and and so the whole purpose of
yoga is to have this spiritual awakening
in your life where you achieve
self-awareness god consciousness christ
consciousness there's a lot of terms for
it but it means
coming to a realization that you are god
which is the polar opposite of the truth
so so i'm going to be devil advocate
just for a second how can how can a pose
become
a style of worship you know i mean
because i mean i've seen people
granted i've never been to a yoga class
but i have seen things on commercials
and stuff where you're saying okay put
yourself in this position then they say
then they go in and almost preach like a
sermon talking about how your body's
becoming more with nature or something
like this
and that's dangerous but how can a pose
be dangerous
i like the way you illustrate it
actually i don't think it's the pose
that is as dangerous
as
the traditional belief that goes along
with the pose and then it's associated
and then it's connected in the mind of a
person and becomes a portal to demonic
influence in a person's life because um
like i've seen kids kid around and say
do that right like they're meditating
because they see in all these cartoons
the lion king
like uh yeah lion king what was the
monkey's rafiki rafiki yeah he's sitting
there like that so it's a cool kind of
trendy thing to do not knowing that
that's the gaian mudra
what
really a mudra is a hand motion with a
symbolic meaning that has spiritual
power associated with it
and what it represents the forefinger
represents
the individual soul
uh according to hindu teaching
uh and the thumb represents brahman
oh wow ottman is the word for soul
and then brahman and when you do that
it's a prayerful statement that as you
meditate and do yoga you will become one
with brahman wow and so it's an
invocation in the form of a hand and you
will see like a like a lot of musicians
and stuff throw that over their eyeball
and making a 666 and stuff i think it's
all you know associated and so that's
when it becomes like here's a little kid
doing yeah right here
yeah he's got his hands up like that
well that's so dangerous so it's not
actually hand motion but it's the idea
that you're presenting in the hand
motion
that you get into your head that causes
the danger in other words right right
well
that particular thing
you know somebody could be kidding
around and do that and
never suffer any kind of repercussion
from it
but if you're doing it seriously as a
meditator
it's going to connect you with a demonic
force right that's what i try to tell
people too and they're like look i saw
that pastor he was doing this hand sign
and it's like look sometimes when you're
talking and you're trying to say like
yeah and you're trying to your hands are
talking and you're saying it was a very
precise thing or something
like you just did it exactly
this is how i got to talk because
somebody's going to screenshot me doing
that and say i'm part of the illuminati
or something but
the thing is is i i just tell people
like there's a difference if you're
taking somebody's gesturing while
they're talking or if it's like
hey let's pose for a picture you know
and it's like if you're posing that way
then you're throwing it up for a reason
if your hands just do something in the
middle of talking then it's probably
just you know you know that that child
is in
the lotus position or not really fully
exactly his feet would be up on his uh
upper legs like an inverted cross if he
was fully in the lotus position but the
there's a reason they call it the lotus
position because uh that's a picture of
the lotus flower there
and
it grows in bodies of water
where
uh
the
the bottom of the flower is on the
bottom of the pond but the leaves and
the flowers are up above the water okay
and so it symbolically represents
rising above the lower nature because it
the root system is in real muddy mucky
ground which
represents the lower nature of the evil
side of human beings
are you going to get into the chakras
and stuff
uh am i going to yeah yeah we'll mention
that
the next pose that i can mention
is a real simple pose it's called the
tree pose
and uh that's where you're standing with
one foot on your upper thigh
and um now the hands are in a prayer
position yeah well so that's looks
religious just in that sense you know
well like the nama stage yesterday right
you ever heard that yes
where uh
a hindu or a yoga advocate or someone
will clasp their hands like this and
give a humble bout which is kind of a
to use the word again a humble and kind
way of greeting a fellow human being but
to say namaste right means i bow to the
divine essence in you wow or i
acknowledge that you are my god i'm in
the presence of a god and you're doing
it to each other so it's like this
mutual thing situation
very different but this particular pose
is dedicated to vishnu and vishnu is one
of the three main gods in the hindu
pantheon and
they believe in 330 million gods and
goddesses
or at least that's the traditional
number
every family can have its own god every
city can have its own god
but this particular pose when people go
to a yoga studio and they assume that
pose and it's called the tree pose they
don't realize
that they are worshiping what is called
the preserver god
you've got three main gods at the head
of the pantheon the first is brahma
which is different than brahman
there's no end on the end brahma is
supposedly the creator god
vishnu is the preserver god and shiva
is the destroyer of god and we'll get to
sheba in just a moment
and there's some really shocking things
about shiva one thing i think about we
were talking about is it the pose itself
that's bad or whatever i think
you're giving a sign to the spirit world
that
you're inviting them in
aware unaware it's just like when you
have a false god in your home like i
used to have all these i loved religious
art even when i was not christian at all
i loved religious art so i had a
crucifix i had a candle with jesus on it
i had a buddha i had this little goat
and all these different things i just
liked the way they looked now when i
became a christian
i'm i still appreciate art so i had all
these sculptures and i was studying with
this guy and he goes
i don't know if you should have those
things i said well it's not like i'm
worshiping him you know i just like the
little statue of buddha i think it looks
cool when he goes
yeah but i still think you know you
should get rid of him and so i i
you know talked with god about that and
i felt convicted yeah i need to get
these false gods out of my house
and i did i threw them away
and what i'm getting at is whether
you're doing something because it's art
or whatever
i don't think we know that half of what
gives satan a right to come in or demons
that come around and it could be
some little statue it could be you're
doing a pose that links back to these
false systems of worship and satan's
like all right you're inviting me in
well i believe there's degrees of danger
like you could have a yoga class where
the teacher is a professing christian
dedicated christian they play christian
music
no mention of hindu doctrine or deities
ever takes place and all you're doing is
physical exercises
there's a possibility that you could go
through that without being contaminated
but i tell people i still would not do
it avoid the very presence of evil
absolutely
and because i am
if i'm known as a christian in the
community and i go to that yoga class
then i am endorsing
yoga
in a public statement you might
influence another christian to say well
i saw my pastor doing yoga and they go
into the other studio a class that's not
led by a christian that doesn't have
christian music that doesn't have a
christian emphasis
and bam they get sucked into a
non-christian worldview causing a
brother to stumble yeah it's the same
the appearance of evil yeah so i i tell
people to break off i've got a little
booklet called seven reasons i no longer
practice yoga i think we did a program
on it one time
and that's one of the reasons where can
they get that book uh at the
truelight.net surely.net the true life
relay.net.net right and they can
download my story
about how i came out of yoga
on that website too right at the
beginning when you scroll down the
second frame you come to has the booklet
i gave you earlier
uh the highest adventure encountering
god and i tell my whole story how i was
a teacher of yoga at four universities
and running a yoga ashram back in 1970
can you believe it's been 51 years
50 coming up on 52 years wow
all right next pose next pose is the
dancer pose i told you this was going to
be a heavy heavy one
this is a picture of sheba
who is the destroyer god
in hinduism
shiva is the one that causes the
destruction and rebirth of the universe
you know during cycles right in hinduism
you have a cyclical view of the future
because you go through ages that are
you know unbelievable amounts of years
like 432 000 years or something like
that they're called yugas
and and you go through these ages
where you go from a golden age down to
an age of complete
debased living and the world becomes
completely corrupt then the whole thing
is destroyed
at a certain point
and reborn again but it happens over and
over again there's no final resolution
in the bible there's a spiritual being
known as the destroyer who's that
well
he seeks to kill and destroy right so
yeah i think that's the devil yeah you
know people say a destr uh destroy um
angel of death went through egypt that's
not what the bible says right it says
the destroyer went oh okay yeah but yeah
i was thinking of when it says he
he seeks to
kill and destroy or something like that
yeah and jesus destroyed the works of
the devil so he destroyed the destroyer
oh yeah but sheba
is called
the lord of yoga
really the lord of yoga and he's often
depicted in a dancing pose shiva's a he
yeah yeah okay i didn't know that he
does not have seen well
like there he looks masculine but i've
seen his lipstick on females
i've seen a female shiva's i thought and
the name just sounds feminine yeah
well
it gets worse you know the uh i can't
remember the name of what they call it
but it's where they speed up
uh
the uh on tumblr
yeah yeah where they've got the what's
miles miles pedron collider yeah yeah
thank you very much
the collider
but outside of that building is a statue
of sheep
and they yeah and the workers all did
the shiva dance and everything and like
this ritual in front of it and so talk
about synchronicity right uh that's the
lord of yoga who is the destroyer the
destroyer god in hinduism shiva is
outside of a building that some
scientists say could cause the
destruction of that i think
stephen hawking said that you're messing
with something that you don't know
anything about you can literally destroy
the universe so anyway every time a yoga
advocate gets in that pose whether they
recognize it or not they're honoring
sheba wow it's an invocation to sheba to
come and manifest in their bodies and in
their lives
next and this is a very common yoga pose
it's called the warrior pose
the warrior two pose
is
honoring uh ganesha
and ganesha is half man half elephant
interesting and there's a myth about how
that happened apparently um
shiva's
consort
a goddess
created
this being
to be a guard at the door of their home
sheba was away and when sheba comes back
to the house
he refuses him entranced into his own
home so he lops his head off oh wow yeah
bad news
and finds out this is a creation of his
consort like a wife a
female goddess so he sends his servants
down to the earth with the order
uh to cut off the head of the first
living thing they come to
unfortunately the first thing was an
elephant they cut the head off bring the
head up to the celestial sphere i guess
stick the elephant head on this guy so
for the rest of his existence he's half
man half elephant now just for the
viewers
um where are the these little
descriptions what what source are you
using this isn't just your own biased
christian opinion right no no i've got
everything footnoted in fact if they
want to see the article they can go to
the truelight.net okay and it's posted
under writings
and they can get all the footnotes and
and it's not just christian sources
original sources
okay
if they do the splits pose i'd like to
see you do that yeah i'll just say
that'd be a tough one for me what about
you no way
if you do the splitspose you're honoring
hanuman
who is the monkey god
and he's considered the god of wisdom
courage strength devotion and
self-discipline again with the praying
hands looking up to the heavens
so it all looks very religious and very
connected with
uh higher
things
and oh oh we see this one we get to
krishna now yeah uh krishna of course is
a very revered hindu deity
and when you make this stand see the
woman with their fingers like this is
depicting playing the flute
because she's the
krishna is depicted playing the flute
and by the flute he attracts all these
women who follow after him see it's very
much like pam i know that's what i was
thinking yeah very much like pan
but um
according to hindu writings you know i
met the head of the
krishna consciousness movement here in
the united states out in california in
los angeles i spent about an hour
talking to him i also went to the
the krishna temple in west virginia and
spent about two or three hours
talking to the head swami there and
unfortunately i wasn't able to convert
either of them but why would you believe
in someone who according to their sacred
writings
married 16 108 women while he was alive
on the earth and had 10 children by each
one of those women
so that's how many that's 161 080
children where are they
where is that
that dna passing down all right
uh half gone on earth well yeah on earth
wow yeah so
so anyway that that
decreases the believability so they
believe that there's some of these like
demigods on earth
you know what i don't know that i'm not
sure but uh i would imagine so i would
imagine they do believe that you would
have to marry a wife every other day of
his life if he lived 100 years did you
just do that i did
and i was like there's no way because
even music people
i don't remember the myth exactly but he
married almost all of them at one time
in one ceremony
interesting the beatles has a song but
you can't have sex with everybody at the
same time right my sweet lord my sweet
lord harry krishna
krishna yeah and everybody say oh yeah i
slowed about jesus and all stuff but no
i mean it says my sweet lord
yeah george harrison wrote that he said
he said he said hallelujah to make you
have this false sense of comfort and
then he'd slip in the hairy christian on
there he said that and then i've
actually seen the beatles throwing up
this hand sign so
yeah they were they were huge into this
new age movement who would who would
think by doing that in a yoga studio
you're honoring
oh god she doesn't exist can you zoom in
on that on that lady yeah i want to see
she can i can't see her very well and
maybe we can't see her
so she has the two almost like uh the
the the devil horns yeah that's what i'm
saying yeah i noticed that too throwing
up the horns
fascinating i didn't know that was a
sign i wonder if that's where devilhorn
sign comes from
right i don't know well i think it's you
know satan is
cross culturally that's a mudra
again yeah
right the next one is
well there's the now here is kind of one
that will shake you it's called the
goddess pose
can you imagine assuming that pose that
takes a lot of physical progress i'm
sure to be able to do that and to be
steady and balanced
but that posed
and in yoga studios when they do the
goddess pose
more often than not they know they're
honoring
khalid wow and kali is the most vicious
vile
goddess
in the hindu pantheon and she's
depicted there with a decapitated head
she's got her foot on sheba
and uh she's got bloody hands
a necklace of skulls wow and a bloody
sword
why would you
worship that there's colleague cults
over in india they get into the weirdest
most evil things something you said
about the the people who are doing this
pose
know what they're doing and stuff it
made me think about that these yoga
studios are literally like a church that
all their congregation comes to and then
there's one person everybody's looking
to like a pastor
and they're saying hey do this to
worship god
but they
you know they're deceiving so many
people that probably don't have any clue
what they're doing right they're like an
evangelist for these heathen deities and
they're like okay everybody do this and
then it's like yep you're doing it but
see cauli becomes for them a symbol that
is like a feminist symbol
like the modern empowerment because
she's got her foot on a man yeah you
know she's rising up above this god i'm
i'm almost 100 positive that's a
depiction of shiva under her feet
so
they like that empowerment right you
know i'm a strong woman so i'm going to
yield
to kali that's k-a-l-i
they're opening their heart to demonic
infants and infestations
all you got to do for the crocodile pose
lay flat on your face and cross your
arms like this and you're honoring rama
wow
another
hindu god
i noticed a lot of the blue
guns that makes me think of that movie
uh avatar yeah
i wonder if there's some interesting
connection there right well that the
director of that james cameron he says
that he
well he says he wrote terminator too he
said that he got terminator the idea for
terminator while he was sick and had a
dream and he dreamed about this metallic
skeleton walking out of the fire
and uh back in the same time period back
in the terminator days in the 80s he had
a dream about
avatar which was that that world was
called uh with
pandora or something like that he had a
dream about those
luminous trees and everything and he had
dreamed about the blue girl
and he said he drew he had a painting of
her and he said but the technology for
movies wasn't good enough back then to
illustrate what he vision envisioned so
he said then later that became avatar a
dream he had and i think he showed up
the
paint
like way long time ago oh yeah yeah and
it's exactly yeah
blue female ready for the next one let's
do it this one's called the cat cow pose
it's like the cat puking pose
hair ball
but anyway uh
it's the female deity saraswati who is
the consort
of brahma you know all the gods have
goddesses
and
she's supposedly the goddess of
education and learning so when you're
doing that
uh cat cow pose and you bend your back
in and bend your back out
over and over you're honoring this
female deity
and then this one is a very recognizable
series of poses it's called it's called
the sun salutation which usually a yoga
session starts out with especially if
it's on the beach or someplace like that
in the morning then they'll do the sun
salutation
and when they do see the the picture on
the right let me raise it up
is a picture of the sun god
surya
s-u-r-y-a
and the sun salutation which is a series
of 12 poses
is honoring sorya so
if you're in a yoga class and you say
i'm a christian
and you go through those poses you just
honored a false god right because the
the son is not a deity
of course in hinduism and many other
religions they associate various parts
of the universe with different deities
like the earth is
uh
geya
that's not the hindu term for it but uh
they associate different deities with
different
parts of the universe
and uh
god uh one with his universe i just
looked up the dictionary term for salute
salutation as a salute you're literally
going to this and they're saying all
right we're going to do the sun
salutation and salute means a gesture of
respect or homage
or polite recognition or acknowledgement
especially one two or made by a person
when arriving departing so you salute
somebody you're in the military they're
over you and you salute them so you're
literally
saluting in respect and homage to the
sun
and it's not even hidden and if you
salute to an officer you're
making a declaration that you're under
submission to his authority right
through and they literally call it the
sun salutation now in romans chapter 1
verse 25 god said they have exchanged
the truth of god for falsehood
by worshiping and serving created things
rather than the creator
praised be he forever and that's the
complete jewish bible version of that
scripture romans 1 25.
so quite often
various expressions of religion
tend to focus on what they can see
instead of what they can't see instead
of enduring and seeing him who is
invisible which is what moses did
they associate god with visible things
because it helps them
connect in faith i believe
so yoga poses our invocations
to hindu deities but what's really
happening i have another scripture here
first corinthians chapter 10
verses 19 and 20
paul
was warning against idolatry
and he actually was referring to food
that was offered to idols
and he said what am i trying to say am i
saying that food offered to idols has
some significance or that idols are real
gods
no not at all i am saying that these
sacrifices are offered to demons not to
god and i don't want you to participate
with demons wow and of course he went on
to say you can't sit at the lord's table
and at the table of demons
what what
concord has christ with bilio what
fellowship has light with darkness and
that's probably the
go-to answer for somebody that's doing
it well i don't believe in other gods
anyway there's only one god but there's
only one god and i don't believe in
these false gods but
you don't have to they're literally
demons right right and and that's why
there's a source of power yeah
associated with it see sheba
has a consort shakti
and shakti
the goddess shakti
is supposedly
the
power
that is at the base of the spine
that they call kundalini you know in
yoga they the whole purpose of the
asanas which is the physical exercises
and the pranayama which is the breathing
exercises and incidentally the reason
they do the breathing exercise they
believe
that the essence of god is in everything
including the molecules in the air and
they call and the the particles of the
divine essence are called breathing in
divinity yeah are called prana and and
so as you
intensify your breathing you're
heightening your awareness of god but i
have a little acrostic i use
y-o-g-a
you only get air
you can't you can't breathe your way
into a relationship with god but anyway
this power supposedly at the base of
your spine
is that associated with shakti
it rises up
through meditation in serpentine fashion
like a serpent until it merges with
sheba in the crown chakra you know
they're supposedly
they're imaginary they don't exist but
supposedly seven chakras in the body and
now this is why i wanted you to bring up
the chakras because this got a picture
of that again it's not your
christian bias that says it's going up
like a serpent this is their own
terminology yeah they're saying that
they want to get the serpent from their
spine or the base
to their crown they want the serpent to
go to their mind well the reason they
depict it as a serpent is because just
like a serpent
rests in a coil position then it
releases
and it's much longer you know
so
this divine essence this essence of
divinity is dormant within every person
like a coiled resting serpent that's not
really manifested in their lives their
lives are all about working making money
paying bills having a wife having
children getting food
they don't care about spiritual matters
but uh
and so most people are bound to that
living within the five senses and
gratifying those senses but they say
when the serpent power is aroused then
shakti comes into union with sheba it's
like a
divine marriage it's like a
sexual overtones to this awakening of
consciousness
and it's dangerous i have people call me
from all over the world they come to our
website that you've already mentioned
the truelight.net
and they see the testimonies there and
then they'll contact us
begging me to pray for them because
they've been in meditation classes and
yoga classes and started having these
weird creations
weird manifestations in their body and
surges of energy through their body and
it drives them close to insanity i'm
sure you've heard way more testimonies
than i have about this stuff but that's
what i always hear is like i started
doing meditation and i started doing the
yoga because it was good for my body or
whatever but then
as i was doing this i started having
these
epiphanies or visitations with ascended
masters and things it would happen just
from doing yoga and meditation they
weren't even trying to do that they
weren't like okay i'm going i'm desiring
to have a interaction with a some kind
of ascended master it just started
happening yeah and then they get sucked
into it because it's like oh this must
be real this is some reality that i i
believe in now because i've experienced
it
now these are
uh
supposedly again
they don't exist in fact the guru i
studied under taught
that the seven chakras are just
imaginary wow he said they don't exist
they're just an aide to meditation
but you have the root chakra sacral
chakra chakra solar plexus chakra that's
the third from the bottom heart chakra
throat chakra
the third eye chakra and the crown
chakra
and so
supposedly as you do all of these
yoga pulses that we just went through
this awakening of the kundalini is going
to take place
and you can depart your body through the
third eye
and and become one with brahman through
the crown chakra we did an episode on
holy yoga um it was a lady it's i think
she's married to
the guy who owns pure flicks or
something like that but she does this
whole
holy yoga class it's christian yoga
and i started looking into her website
to see
is it anything christian about it and
she said i was looking at those chakras
like she has she's all into this chakra
stuff as a christian and she said and
god showed me
that right in the crown shot or right in
the heart chakra was the um the star of
david and she's like and i don't believe
the bible ever mentions anything about
this
symbol being in a good thing i mean it's
a hexagram it's an ancient occultic
symbol we've known it to be the star of
david and associated with israel and
biblical christianity or whatever but
she said that god showed her that um
the star of david right there and the
heart chakra and it was just like she
said it was like she wept and and felt
god and everything and most experienced
holy yoga is a mixture of eastern
philosophy and
biblical ideas
and um
i've heard brook boone the founder of
uh in an interview she did with a hindu
guy and she said there was nothing wrong
with yoga back when she practiced it
before becoming a christian wow i think
she's a nice person and i think she
loves jesus but i think she's got a big
mix going on
true and false ideas and that's the
error that we have to be
looking for in these last days man it's
going to be so deceptive
but uh you know yoga means yoke yeah and
the bible said be not unequally yoked
with unbelievers but jesus said come
unto me all you that labor in the heavy
laden and i will give you rest he said
take my yoke upon you there you go but
his yoke is not yoga yeah
his joke is acting and reacting
like he would in the same circumstance
learning his character then
becoming one with him in such a way that
you can forgive like he forgave and you
can walk in humility like he did
i mean it seems like i mean i think it
is
like uh
spiritual adultery
oh yes i mean because you know as a
christian you know
i mean we go over there and we go with
another gods and everything i mean not
knowing right i mean that's the
that's the danger thing like not knowing
that you're doing all this practicing
and you're thinking well that's
exercising everything
but literally i mean that's from
different deities and different gods and
and the thing is that
it's not just like a
a decent loving god right like a nice
pagan guy you know
i mean i'm not saying you know it's
right or wrong but it's like yeah just
to see those pictures and all those yeah
even just a rational secular person
should say why would i worship a god of
destruction i don't know right i mean
yeah i mean it looks very
uh ominous yeah very like wow what's
going on yeah we're in a relationship
we're in a covenant marriage
relationship with jesus and he says that
that the people they went are whoring
after strange gods i mean that's exactly
what's happening yeah yeah you're
inviting in and you're in your mind and
like you were saying like man later on
you're gonna be hearing these voices man
to do this and to do that and
and
you know worship this and then
somebody's gonna come to you and say hey
uh
we weren't gonna come to church now i
don't wanna go to church in the morning
i gotta do my yoga i gotta do my yoga oh
i want to go
i don't know
so i think we need to be really careful
with that amen a little stretching
i i believe if somebody really were to
dig into this and see
what the nature of yoga is that they
would never participate in the yoga
class i agree i think a lot of this is
just
a desire to want to know the truth about
things we the stuff that we talk about
on this show
anybody could research i mean where did
the origins of superheroes come from
they'll tell you they're greek and roman
gods i mean it doesn't we're not having
to make this stuff up they will tell you
same with this stuff if i i've done it
before i've searched online what is yoga
first thing it says is it originates
from some religion you know well even
hindu leaders say there's no hinduism
without yoga and no yoga without
hinduism exactly you can't separate the
spiritual level yeah yeah and
jesus very clearly spoke against the
practices in his opening sermon sermon
on the mount matthew 6 7 he said use not
vain repetitions as the heathen
but they think that they'll be heard for
their much speaking
and
why did he call them vain repetitions
because it's a vain attempt at becoming
one with god
if you were going to communicate with a
friend would you step into the living
room where that person was and repeat
the same thing a thousand times and a
monotone voice to earn their attention
wow or would they throw you in the loony
bin right
yeah that's a good way to play guys
personally you would not approach a
fellow human being
with that kind of mechanical approach of
chanting them monotone chant with the
same words over and over like a wife
chanting to her husband please take out
the garbage please take out the garbage
all she's got to do is go in there and
say honey would you mind taking out the
garbage yes because i love you and god
is a god is a person he's not a machine
and it's not something you manipulate
and control with the right incantation
that's right but
and there's other things we we talked
about the third eye
in the close of this little teaching
what people attribute and let me see if
i can get it on my computer i think
yeah i've got it right here people say
that jesus taught the third eye because
of the scripture
that they pull out of context and that's
matthew chapter 6 same sermon sermon on
the mount matthew chapter 6
verses 22 and 23 he said the light of
the body is the eye
if therefore thine i be single thy whole
body shall be full of light that's the
king james version because other
versions don't convey this idea
but if that i be evil thy whole body
shall be full of darkness and therefore
the the light that is in thee be
darkness how great is that darkness
so
this eye of light is the third eye what
do they think about this
that's the third eye what do they think
about when it says if thy and i be evil
so your third eye can be evil or good
yeah you can have evil psychic powers or
righteous righteous psychic
if the third eye is activated if the
third eye is functional then you have
perception powers on a level that normal
human beings don't have or at least
that's what they teach
and they think that jesus was in a very
esoteric way
revealing that he believed in the
chakras but
that's what you call
instead of uh
studying this passage in the context
it's not exegesis it's isages
where where you're making this means
something else by pulling it out of
context uh
because if you go to the the verses
before this statement it's all about
being a spiritual person instead of a
material person
he starts off by saying lay not for
yourselves treasures upon the earth
where moth and rust does corrupt where
thieves break through and steal but lay
up for yourselves treasures in heaven
where neither moth nor rust does corrupt
nor thieves do not break through nor
steel for where your treasure is there
will your heart be also the light of the
body is the eye in other words your
perception of what's important in life
there you go it makes sense and if you
think wealth and riches and material
things are important
then it's going to be darkness
in your life yeah it's almost like uh
so isn't there a verse it might even be
in here where it says um
where your heart is well that yeah
that's what you just said where your
treasure is there where your heart be on
yeah so what you focus on is where your
heart's at if you focus on that car
that's your heart and that's a that's
not a good and then after he says the
light of the body is the eye if
therefore then i be single thy whole
body shall be full of light then the
verse after it he says you cannot serve
god amen
if he was talking about a chakra he
would have said to his disciples you
need to meditate for hours so that you
can become aware of this energy center
that needs to be aligned
but instead he said you can't serve god
and mammon he's not talking about a
spiritual energy center he's talking
about being a spiritual minded person
yeah and then he went on to um
say no man can serve two masters he will
either hate the one and love the other
or else he will hold to the one and
despise the other you cannot serve god
and mammon
now the complete jewish bible
translates the word
hapless
which is which is
rendered
differently in the complete jewish bible
see the word
that is translated single if thy not be
single
in the king james version in other
versions it's if thine eye is sound or
true or good or healthy
you know if you have a good outlook on
life if you have a sound way of
perceiving what life is so this is
probably truer to the original hebrew
per greek i guess and in the complete
jewish bible the same passage is
rendered this way
the eye is the lamp of the body so if
you have a good eye instead of if your
eye be single right if you have a good
eye that is if you are generous
your whole body will be full of light
you'll live a fulfilling life yeah that
makes a lot more sense a human being
that sympathizes with others
if you have a good eye but if you have
an evil eye and then in brackets it says
if you are stingy
your whole body will be full of darkness
and that fits in with the context it's
contextually
correct to see it that's why it's good
to look at context as well as look at a
concordance if this is you know
confusing to you which it was to me
honestly when i saw it i still don't
understand the whole single part
you just brought it out in the original
greek it's not single it's more sound or
true which makes a lot of sense
yeah if you have a healthy outlook on
life so anyway
that's all about yoga poses and all
about uh
chakras and all the stuff associated
with yoga that makes me want to flee
from a yoga studio amen we were told to
come out of her be not partakers of
these sins and you know be separate from
the world a lot of the world is going
into this stuff thank you so much for
sharing that the dangers of yoga and how
it's potentially giving homage to
deities like the sun and all these pagan
gods if you know somebody that's into
yoga and you don't know exactly how to
tell them
what's wrong with it we hope that this
was beneficial to you because that's
what we try to do on this show is to
educate we want to give you those
answers why something is dangerous why
something is bad and
to make that decision on your own to
stay away from it so thank you again and
we want to tell people that they can go
to your website at the true light the
truelight.net and incidentally there's
lots of stories there of people that
were
in the depth of studying yoga one guy
michael graham was a personal student of
mukhtan and lived in an ashram in india
for 20 years wow
another woman was a world acclaimed
yoga teacher who uh was one of the
teachers in an ashram in australia and
she recently gave her heart to the lord
has a phenomenal story so anyone who is
a sincere seeker after truth
these are not people that just went to a
few yoga classes and decided now i'm
going back to my baptist church or
whatever you know these are people that
seriously went after the far eastern new
age worldview and found out they can
only be fulfilled in jesus and that's
the true light.net
lots of articles lots of podcasts tv
shows
all kinds of resources on that website
that will help a person make a decision
for the truth awesome we're so thankful
for that resource because i know it's
going to help so many people well thank
you guys so much for being with us again
this week if you were blessed by this
please give us a simple free thumbs up
it really helps get this out there get
into the algorithm so many people can
see it and like i said we cannot do this
without your support we love you guys
and we thank you for joining us and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
you